el próximo 7 de agosto y bando que deja
a la casa de nariño y la presidencia de
colombia a la espera de un cambio de
mando en el país y en la cuenta
regresiva de las elecciones vamos a
revisar qué país deja el mandatario y la
conversación sobre este tema es con
jorge iván cuervo docente e investigador
de la facultad de gobierno y relaciones
internacionales de la universidad
externado de colombia jorge gracias por
acompañarnos en el estudio de france 24
buenos dias angela y muy contenta estar
acá conversando con ustedes vamos a
comenzar hablando de lo que sucedió hace
poco más de un año el levantamiento
social que empezó contra una reforma
tributaria al final fallida y que dejó
una de las mayores crisis de este
gobierno en el primer aniversario cuál
es su conclusión de los protestas y de
los problemas que edu que no logró
abordar y un comentario antes dijo duke
sin embargo que logró en su gobierno el
mayor crecimiento económico en casi 115
años pues sabe yo creo que estos cuatro
años hay que admirarlos no sólo en el
contexto de las protestas sino también
yo creo que en el contexto de la
pandemia creo que los temas están
relacionado ustedes por ejemplo por esto
último el crecimiento económico fue
justo después de que bajaron los altos
niveles de la pandemia se retomaron las
actividades económicas en los distintos
sectores y eso decían los economistas
que iba a producir un efecto rebote muy
rápidamente entonces hay uno entraría a
dudar si ese crecimiento que en realidad
es
cierto corresponde o es una consecuencia
de las políticas del gobierno no es el
contexto global se vio que la economía
creció por razones
digamos lógicas desde haberse retomado
la actividad económica la mayoría de los
países el tema de las protestas yo creo
que
marca lo que es el escenario hoy de las
de las elecciones sí
un caso similar un poco lo que pasó en
chile si uno mira en chile también hubo
protestas sociales un estallido social y
terminaron en dos situaciones políticas
una convención que va a producir una
nueva constitución cuyo texto acaba ya
de ser entregado y un gobierno de
izquierda si en colombia no se hicieron
las reformas institucionales que se
demandaron en esas reformas si esas
quedaron aplazadas allí todo indica que
no la vamos a jugar es por las
elecciones entonces la gran pregunta que
nos vamos a hacer ahora después de la
primera vuelta o en la segunda es el
resultado leerlo a la luz de qué pasó en
esas protestas sociales y yo creo que
eso de alguna manera explica que la
intención de voto la tenga nunca el
candidato de izquierda que es el que
mejor ha interpretado y canalizado de
ese inconformismo social y eso a la luz
jorge también de que en colombia no
hemos tenido hasta el momento un
gobierno de la izquierda pero ahora
quisiera que habláramos en el ámbito
nacional no en los ámbitos en los
gobiernos locales y claro por supuesto
pero no en la presidencia y eso sería un
cambio grandísimo si llegara a suceder
después de las elecciones de ésta pero
otro tema sobre el que usted quería
conversar que es una noticia reciente el
gobierno de edu que asegura que dejó
cumplido el plan nacional de desarrollo
hasta el 70 por ciento entonces en ese
ámbito económico y en ese contexto de
pandemia pues que hay que decir sobre
eso claro yo creo que hay como tres
escenarios donde uno puede evaluar si un
gobierno ha cumplido o no lo que se
prometió uno el más técnico que quizás
el que al ciudadano no le interesa y que
en los medios puede ser muy muy muy
pesado por decirlo así en un debate es
analizar los documentos técnicos del
gobierno el departamento nacional de
planeación dice hemos cumplido el 70 por
ciento de las metas de los distintos
sectores y uno mira y seguramente eso
eso es así porque los gobiernos
tienen una métrica de medición de sus
proyectos que corresponde con lo que
siempre sucede pero hay otros dos
escenarios en los que uno mide la
edificación gobierno primero la
aprobación de los ciudadanos del
gobierno entonces uno dice bueno
en las últimas encuestas él se ha
mantenido una desaprobación del gobierno
de un 65 por ciento y esa es otra forma
de ver si un gobierno está haciendo
exitosa y hay uno tercero más que si yo
creo que es el que es más visible para
los ciudadanos y para los medios de
comunicación y es el que uno llamaría
como la conducción política que tiene un
gobierno sobre el país y entonces ahí yo
creo que si uno ve muchísimas
dificultades en los temas mucho más
macro si el tema del deterioro de la
seguridad pública en muchas regiones por
ejemplo el tema de la parálisis de 11
departamentos por el tema del plan del
golfo el aumento de la muerte de líderes
sociales el deterioro de muchas regiones
como el catatumbo como el pacífico
nariñense como choco el aumento de los
desplazamientos forzados y esos otros
datos también dan cuenta de la eficacia
de un gobierno sí y además un planes de
seguridad que viene puede ser legado del
uribismo de muchos años de uribismo en
el país en colombia
y hay cifras cifras que hablan muy en
contra de esos planes solo en el 2022
jorge son 75 líderes sociales asesinados
20 firmantes de los acuerdos de paz que
fueron asesinados ni hablar de más de
200 masacres que aquejan al país este
fenómeno se puede atribuir al manejo que
iván duque le ha dado a la
implementación de los acuerdos de paz en
colombia' yo creo que si hay una
relación es decir el acuerdo de paz con
las farc en una oportunidad que tenía el
estado colombiano de replantear por
decirlo así la gobernabilidad y en
general las acciones del gobierno pero
el gobierno del presidente duque no pudo
hacer ese ese digamos ese paso a
gobernar en un escenario de post acuerdo
un escenario de post conflicto no siguió
atado a una narrativa de que era un
acuerdo que había sido derrotado en las
urnas que había dejado al país inundado
de coca y fue incapaz de construir un
escenario de gobernabilidad más allá del
poso del post acuerdo y claro cuando el
estado no hace presencia en los en
muchas zonas donde hay rentas ilegales
en juego en cultivos ilícitos minería
ilegal pues los los actores armados
ilegales aparecen de 9 cuando ya el
estado quiere retomar el control es un
poco tarde es cuando uno mira el
fenómeno de los de la muerte de líderes
sociales y de firmantes del acuerdo de
paz sea justamente en esas zonas donde
uno diría debilidad de la presencia
estatal muchas rentas ilegales y ya una
a una dificultad enorme del gobierno y
de la fuerza pública para retomar el
control que sería el punto de partida
del gobierno no de duke no entendió que
con el acuerdo de paz había un nuevo
escenario de gobernabilidad política que
seguramente le hubiera dado resultados
distintos a los que hoy tenemos no mire
es que cuando un grupo armado es capaz
de tomarse 11 de 32 departamentos eso
muestra una total de eficiencia pues en
el plan de seguridad de un gobierno
están ahí las pruebas pero además vamos
a hablar de esta dimensión humana según
el fondo monetario internacional en 2021
del pib e subió sobre el 10 por ciento
para este se espera un crecimiento
superior al 4% y esas son cifras pues
muy positivos de cara a los números y a
las estadísticas pero esto se enfrenta a
las cifras de pobreza alrededor del 40
por ciento de la población claro sin
olvidar que esto sucedió también durante
una pandemia clark pero eso no es sólo
un problema del gobierno de duke deseos
algo que no llamaría un problema como
del modelo en sí mismo sí y es en qué
medida el buen crecimiento económica y
que como usted dice angela es una
siempre es una buena noticia se traduce
en mejor bienestar para los ciudadanos
ahí ya empezamos a hablar es de la
calidad de las políticas sociales así
como en las políticas educativas en las
políticas de salud de acceso a vivienda
de acceso a servicio de alcantarillado
ese crecimiento realmente le llega
especialmente digamos a las personas más
vulnerables en eso el estado colombiano
en su conjunto los institucionales
necesita hacer un cambio y claro ese
cambio no iba a darse en el actual
gobierno aunque el actual gobierno tiene
para mostrar y eso también es cierto que
por ejemplo como consecuencia de la
pandemia
las llamadas transferencias monetarias
no solo familias en acción sino también
ingresos solidarios y efectivamente
millones de personas recibieron y van a
seguir recibiendo el tema y eso es pues
él se puso en la discusión en la agenda
hoy ya por ejemplo en colombia se habla
sobre que el próximo gobierno tiene que
instaurar una renta básica monetaria a
un número muy importante de hogares en
situación sobretodo de pobreza extrema
como medida de política social entonces
es esa teoría de que el crecimiento
finalmente termina goteando y llegando a
los estratos más más pobres no es
suficiente se necesitan y lo han dicho
los economistas y los organismos
internas políticas sociales si
integrales y sostenibles que tomen ese
crecimiento económico y lo transformen
en bienestar social en los distintos
dimensiones vitales de los hogares
podemos estar de acuerdo en que el
aumento de transferencias monetarias no
implica que la sociedad mejore o que la
pobreza mejoró en el país y se nos queda
por fuera de jorge y va en un tema bien
importante pero pues lo vamos a dejar
nuestros televidentes lo revisen en casa
y esa es la migración no colombiano
solamente siendo uno de los países de
paso para los miles de migrantes que
buscan llegar hacia eeuu sino uno de los
principales receptores de venezolanos un
problema al que el gobierno de iván
duque intentó darle trámite con la
legalización de la estadidad de
venezolanos pero que todavía será un
gran reto para el siguiente gobierno y
dicho eso pues mire empleo de las
gracias por estar con nosotros en france
24 y vamos a estar todos atentos seguro
usted también a lo que va a pasar este
domingo en las elecciones presidenciales
de acuerdo pero siendo justos en ese
tema de la atención migratoria
especialmente de los migrantes
venezolanos fue una de las cosas en las
que el gobierno duque lo hizo me lo hizo
mejor digamos esa legalización para que
pudieran tener acceso a los servicios
sociales por ejemplo sobre todo en
educación en salud en atención a la
primera infancia en atención a mujeres
en embarazo fue una de las cosas buenas
que hizo el gobierno y se lo han
reconocido
como dice tirios y troyanos